ces évacués vivent dans l'angoisse
depuis cinq jours à l'idée de revoir
leur maison ou ce qu'il en reste les
autorités leur ont offert une visite en
autobus dans les quartiers dévastées
maintenant que le feu est en partie
maîtrisé
la visite est organisée pour ceux dont
la maison est détruite ou tellement
endommagées qu'il n'est plus habitable
il y a 150 maisons dans cet état Jodie
twurt a décidé de ne pas y aller il sait
que les flammes ont rasé sa maison il a
déjà beaucoup pleuré
ce moment en groupe en regardant ma
propriété à travers une fenêtre dit-il
il préfère attendre de pouvoir marcher
librement chez lui avec ses proches
les autobus reviennent après une visite
d'environ deux heures personne n'a été
autorisé à descendre du bus mais il y a
eu des arrêts devant les maisons et
l'occasion de filmer la dévastation
Merry et Jayson Yang ont accepté de nous
montrer ce qu'ils ont vu que des ruines
de leur maison familiales de deux étages
le couple savait que la maison était
partie en fumée mais voir ce que les
flammes ont fait c'était comme vivre un
deuil
ça aide à tourner la page et à composer
avec tout ça explique Mary
presque aucune évacuer n'a voulu nous
parler après la visite trop bouleversée
par les ravages du feu certains
pleuraient encore en sortant l'autobus
c'était effrayant c'était silencieux on
s'est réconforté les uns les autres le
Premier ministre Tim Houston s'est rendu
à un centre d'hébergement des évacués
on est tous très désolé pour eux samedi
d'autres évacués pourront aller visiter
les quartiers touchés par le feu et si
la pluie arrive enfin tous les autres
évacués il y en a plus de 16000 pourront
éventuellement y aller aussi ici Michel
rideau Radio-Canada Halifax